senior political analyst Brit Hume joins
us tonight good evening Brit the
president meeting with his cabinet and
military leaders at this hour just told
if the press pool went in if we get that
tape I'll interrupt you here but your
thoughts on the decision-making and what
has been said over the past couple of
days about this this attack well it's
pretty hard to believe that there won't
be some sort of military action coming
out of this the president obviously
would feel obliged to do that since he
so strongly warned Assad the last time
this happened when he did take military
action that I thought it best not do
this again and now as John Roberts noted
he has in fact done that so I suspect
we'll be able to do this there's no
particular risk to US forces we have
these standoff weapons of the kind that
were used the last time and as Israeli
attack illustrates there are military
targets in Syria that are that are open
and vulnerable to a u.s. attack so he
can inflict some some damage on this on
the Syrian regime and just depends on
how he chooses it to do that and how
extensive it is you know we should note
that today is the first day for the new
National Security Advisor John Bolton
what a first day indeed what a first day
and of course as Bolton has said his job
is to make sure the president gets all
the options presented and presumably
that is exactly what is happening in
that meeting in the White House as we
speak at there the president is hearing
from his advisors all the various
possibilities that he has what the
upsides and downsides are of each but I
think the direction here is pretty clear
I want to get your thoughts on this
Cohen raid and the FBI agents a no-knock
raid and that the office and where he
was staying
communications were told between Cohen
and the president thoughts on all of
this this is not the kind of thing the
FBI is involved in on a very often on a
very regular basis I mean rating a
person's lawyer's office where there are
the likelihood of lawyer-client
privilege involved is a rare step and
the question that I have tonight is okay
what's the underlying crime that's being
investigated here the only thing that we
have you know heard in in all of the
stormy Daniels back and forth is that
there's a distinct possibility of a
campaign fine
violation that is to say that the money
that was paid for his silence would be
an effective campaign contribution
because of where it when it happened
just before the election that's all the
crime we know of Brett we got a run here
because we're getting word that this
videotape may be coming soon I got a hit
a break Fred as always thank you